what else uh music music keeps popping
up a lot in your writing
uh were you i'm frustrated uh that's
exactly what i was gonna use yes
you probably noticed the title song of
ice and fire songs of dead men
singing a song for liar
did you have those dreams of being a
rock star when you were a kid
yeah to maybe to some extent i don't
know a rock star
more of a song writer but
i love i love music especially music
with good lyrics
i actually am a songwriter now because i
wrote lyrics for ice and fire songs and
they put them to music in the game of
thrones tv series so
i i am now registered with as cap and i
get music royalties for the bear and the
maiden fair
and the reigns of casca beer so
there you go uh how how did you get
mixed up with hollywood in the first
place because you've been there been
working with them for
quite a while now uh it was all because
a book called the armageddon rag which
of
all my books is that the most rock and
roll
it was my fourth novel and it was
[Music]
supposed to be a gigantic best seller
they paid me a lot of money for it and
nobody bought it so
my career as a novelist was suddenly
over because uh as i told the crowd the
other day
you know this is not a this is not a
profession for anyone who needs security
so
i've been for 10 years i've been a
rising star and suddenly
like many rising stars i rose so far and
then i crashed and burned
and uh but oddly enough
the the very book that destroyed my
career as a novel novelist
opened my career as a screenwriter
because it was optioned for a feature
film by a guy named phil deger
who was a you know big rock and roll guy
i thought it would make a great feature
film and he wanted to write it and
direct it he did write several versions
of the script
never got it produced or financed
but phil was a television guy and uh i
got to know phil by that option
and a couple years later it was phil had
a hit show called simon and simon
and uh you know when you create a hit
show the network wants more
shows from you so they said to phil okay
simon simon's a big hit what else would
you like to do and he said i want to
bring back the twilight zone
so they said okay so they let him bring
back the twilight zone
and he hired me to write a script and
they liked a script and next thing you
know i was on staff on twilight zone
which had i had a successful novel
writing career at the moment i might
have turned down
but since you know i didn't
um this prospect on the job seemed
pretty good to me so i
i took it and spent 10 years on that
you mentioned armageddon rag uh it's it
didn't do well when first came out but
it's definitely found an audience now
i know i've talked to people that have
cited it as one of their favorite books
it's certainly
better than it did initially it's still
the worst selling of all my novels
[Music]
i mean obviously i said fire cells
better than anything else by
huge magnitudes but then then you fall
down from ice and fire to like fever
dream which is next and then
you know then it goes down further and
further until you hit armageddon rag at
the bottom now
admittedly my audience is now so huge
that even my worst selling book
sells better than the best-selling book
of
80 of the writers in the field so i
don't
really have anything to complain about
but i'm glad people like armageddon rag
i put a lot into it it's an important
book to me
it's uh the the rock group you created
for that the not school
right if you could if you could pick
from
any rock stars over the last 50 years to
to play the members of the naw school
who would you choose queen's clearwater
revival
but it's interesting because uh
the the uh the nozzle
have always been like a rorschach test
when apple came out and people would
meet to me they they would always tell
me their theories of of who the nozzle
really were you know who they were
modeled on and
everybody heard them differently and
some people heard the doors or the
rolling stones and
some people heard you know much more
obscure groups you know i've had people
come up at
the nozzle they would have ripped whips
weren't they uh
right yeah the whip rip the ripped whips
i've never heard of them
they were the 13th floor elevators okay
right yeah
but no i always heard them more as
credence and maybe a little bit of doors
morrison you know etc